حدائق أولت منذ أكثر من 40 عامًا وأنا
أنظر دائمًا إلى المنزل كان
تقريبًا محور الحديقة وأن
الحديقة حصلت بالفعل على تدفقات حول
المنزل الواقع في الريف الإنجليزي
هي
حديقة محبوبة للغاية للأمراء البريطانيين حيث
نادرًا ما يتم دعوة الكاميرات
هذا هو Highgrove المسكن الخاص
والحدائق الرائعة التي يشتهر
بها الأمير تشارلز ، وهناك
موضوع مشترك في جميع أنحاء الحديقة
الكاملة لنباتاته المفضلة ذات رائحة الحياة البرية ،
لذا فهذه هي العناصر التي
تجدها تربط جميع الغرف
بجميع مكونات الحدائق مقسمة
إلى  غرف في الهواء الطلق تحتوي كل منها على
مجموعة متنوعة غنية من زوايا الأرضية ،
وهناك
مناظر طبيعية خضراء من السراخس والجذوع مع
مجموعتها الوطنية من
حديقة المنزل الريفي أوستر حيث
تخلق الأشجار والأزهار أعمال شغب من الألوان مستوحاة
من التبت
وحديقة المطبخ حيث تفاح البازلاء
والكمثرى  وغيرها من المنتجات اللذيذة
بشكل عضوي ، وقد تم تصميم كل
منها لتجسيد أصحابها  تطوير المُثُل
والمبادئ العضوية ، ما
هو رائع حقًا إذا كان لدينا شخص
شغوف جدًا بالحديقة
ولا يمكنه الانتظار حتى يخرج إلى الحديقة
عندما يعود إلى المنزل وهو في الواقع
يقود عنصر التصميم وهذا
حقًا  إنها حديقته التي صممها ،
كانت الحدائق مفتوحة للزوار
من أبريل إلى أكتوبر على مدار الخمسة وعشرين
عامًا الماضية وخلال تلك الفترة
جمعت الجولات أكثر من سبعة ملايين
جنيه إسترليني للصندوق الخيري لأمير ويلز